earlier in the show i gave you the
details of this cash crunch that's
hitting the donald trump campaign where
they've already spent
uh more than 70 percent of all the money
they've raised dating
dating back to early 2019 and are having
a pretty serious financial problems we
also already looked at donald trump
yesterday during one of these
deranged press briefings making very
little sense seeming furious about
journalists wearing masks and just
insulting people calling joe biden
stupid
trump also absolutely lost it on twitter
yesterday tweeting and retweeting 70
times in one day now as i've said before
most normal people with regular 40 hour
a week jobs
are too busy to tweet 70 times a day i
make it a point
to try to connect with people on twitter
and to at least do a little bit of
tweeting and
you know i'm not that busy i'm certainly
not the president of the united states
and i'm rarely tweeting more than three
or four times a day and donald trump
with 70
70 tweets and retweets yesterday
take a look at some of the outrageous
things that he tweeted because the
themes are important here
and there's actually a great website
trumptwitterarchive.com
it lets you look at tweets much more at
a glance and look at tweet uh trends and
themes that we see
now earlier in the morning donald trump
retweeted a whole bunch of stuff about
uh black violence and police being good
retweeting a bunch of things from the
always action account
for example black man exposes black
lives matter
police officer saves baby's life
um the reason why president donald trump
was elected and the reason why he will
be elected again with a link to an
outrageous propaganda video so there
were a bunch of those
types of tweets uh earlier on in the day
then trump started insulting people for
example
quote biden underperforming what else is
new
the story of his life attacking john
bolton his former national security
adviser saying
just heard that wacko john bolton
was talking of the fact that i discussed
love letters from kim jong-un
as though i viewed them as just that
obviously
was just being sarcastic bolton was such
a jerk
then around midday remember this is just
it's all day
around midday trump retweeting about 10
tweets from an account called
tvnews hq uh
all propaganda videos fox news videos
being retweeted
uh tweets about the dow which by the way
has not been doing so well stock market
has not been doing well
recently conspiracy theories and all
sorts of agit
trash as i like to call it and then of
course donald trump getting into the
phase of the day where he just lies
about coronavirus
tweeting quote starting to get very high
marks
in our handling of the coronavirus china
virus
especially when compared to other
countries and areas of the world
now the vaccines plus are coming and
fast and we're going to talk on the
friday show
much more in depth about what kind of
impact could we see from the vaccine
announcement that we're expecting in
october from trump not the vaccine
distribution
but the vaccine announcement and of
course donald trump insisting that he's
just done so well on coronavirus
i i yeah i guess there's probably some
people who do believe it there are trump
sycophants who will believe anything
but you know more than 193 000 deaths
when trump said we would have 60 000
deaths maybe by the time it was all said
and done
trump said 15 cases would soon be zero
now with 193
almost 194 000 deaths as of this moment
donald trump insisting that he's just
done really really great
on coronavirus and again going all day
the tweets started at 7am eastern
yesterday
they ended around 9 00 pm all day unless
you
uh uh with the exception of when trump
was doing the press briefing yesterday
afternoon
he's tweeting every hour it it is just
tweets
after tweets after tweet this is not
normal
this is not needed this is not helping
this is
worsening our relationships with our
historical allies
this is very much something other than
actually dealing with the pressing
issues that we're facing today
it does nothing for you the american
people and i know some people write off
the tweets as
not important donald trump has chosen to
communicate
his perspective and his positions to the
world essentially
through twitter and if he is chosen
choosing to use this tool
then certainly we should be using it to
see where trump's head is
and it is not in a good place at all and
it is being reflected in the polls and
that's what i want to talk about next
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a life saver and here's how it
works takes just a couple of minutes to
set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman